بن مرحبًا ، أريد أن أذهب إليك أولاً ، أعني
ما رأيك في هذه الأخبار السارة جدًا ،
على الأقل الإشارات الجيدة والرسائل
التي نخرجها من المنطقة
جيدًا يبدو أنه في اليوم السابع
هناك حركة
نحن فقط  سمع أسامة ربيعة رئيس
هيئة قناة السويس
أه يقول أنه تم نقل السفينة
يقول
80 بالمائة يبدو أن هذا المؤخرة
قد تم
إبعاده عن الضفة الغربية لقناة السويس من
الواضح أن الممر المائي ليس خاليًا بعد ولكن
هذا
مهم  حدث تقدم في
الساعات الأولى من الصباح قبل
شروق الشمس وقد قال إنهم
يأملون في
أن يطفووا فعليًا وأن
يحرروا السفينة تمامًا في حوالي الساعة 11:30 عندما
يحدث المد العالي بعد حوالي ثلاث
ساعات ونصف
من الآن وهم '  إعادة على أمل أنه عندما
يحدث ذلك سيكونون قادرين على نقل
ما تم التخلي عنه إلى البحيرة المرة العظيمة
التي تبعد حوالي
40 30 كيلومترًا إلى الشمال
من أه هناك قال إنه ربما
يمكن استئناف الملاحة بحلول
noo
من الصعب اليوم أن تكون
واثقًا حقًا ولكن
الأخبار التي نحصل عليها من الصور التي
نتلقاها على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
تشير جميعها إلى اتجاه
حل هذه الأزمة التي استمرت أسبوعًا أه من
الواضح أن هناك عمل يتعين القيام به
ربما
هناك حاجة للتجريف في القناة
في المنطقة التي علقت
فيها السفينة نفسها هناك أسئلة
حول صلاحيتها للإبحار
في هذه المرحلة ولكن بالتأكيد يبدو
أن أه
مصر قد تجاوزت أسوأ ما في
هذه المرحلة
روبن وكما  نحن ننظر إلى هذه الصور
بالتأكيد
أخبار جيدة أه ليس فقط لأم الناس هناك
في مصر
ومحاولة عبور قناة المجاري ولكن أيضًا
لحركة
المرور البحرية العالمية تعطينا إحساسًا
بالحجم الهائل لعملية الحنفية أعتقد أن
10 قاطرات
عدد  من المحاولات المختلفة الأخرى التي يجب
القيام بها لمحاولة
تغيير هذا ،
نعم ، لقد كان هذا منذ
بداية هذه الأزمة في
وقت مبكر من صباح الثلاثاء وعلى
مدار الساعة
بجهود السلطات المصرية  أه
لحل هذه المشكلة ضع في اعتبارك أن
أه يجلب في قناة السويس حوالي
5.6 مليار دولار على الأقل في عام 2020 إلى
مصر
ولكن الأهم أنها هيبة
هي
سمعة أمة كانت على المحك
وقد تم التحلي بالكثير من الخفة
حول
تلك الصور لجرثوم واحد
يحاول التجريف حول أه
مقدمة السفينة
ولكن حقيقة الأمر على
الجانب الآخر من السفينة كانت هناك مجموعة متنوعة من
زوارق القطر تحاول دفع السفينة إلى التجمد ،
لذا نعم ، لقد كان هذا جهدًا كبيرًا
من قبل السلطات المصرية بمساعدة
خبراء هولنديين ويابانيين
أيضًا واه أنت تعرف حقًا أن مصر كانت
تحبس أنفاسها في
انتظار حل هذا الأمر
كما قلت مهمًا اقتصاديًا
سياسيًا
ورمزًا واستراتيجيًا.